[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
omnia pillow and we'll be reviewing the
best
and worst multivitamins that you take
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor
sleep and glow company with beauty
pillow omnia so
you guys know i am really particular
about my bedtime routine because
if every little thing isn't perfect and
in its place it's gonna be a bad night
i'm picky about
temperature my weighted blanket and my
pillow
so much so that i always bring my own
with me
wherever i go so i was recently sent
this omnia pillow which was developed by
orthopedists
and cosmetologists and i am officially
sold its unique patented design helps to
support an
optimal sleep position and it uses
memory foam
to perfectly adjust to the shape of your
face neck and shoulders
and because it cradles your face rather
than just like lets your head sink
into it it prevents your skin from
compressing and twisting as you sleep
now i try not to be vain i honestly have
not had
a cosmetic procedure in my life and the
internet tells me all the time that
that's a parent but would i like it if
my skin
looked like it did before i had kids
without paying for
crazy expensive creams or botox why yes
yes i would
so a pillow that will last me five years
that can help prevent
wrinkling and puffiness and keep me cool
and comfortable as i sleep
definitely feels like a good investment
to me
so if you want to try omnia for yourself
check out the link in the description
and use my promo code abbysharp10 for 10
off of your order you can also check out
my disclaimer in the description
and on screen including a reminder that
the information here
is really general and it's very
important that you speak to a health
care provider
before starting or stopping a supplement
regimen
vitamins and minerals are not benign so
please do not be taking them
half-hazardly without knowing about your
unique needs
okay so first of all let's talk briefly
about the whole multivitamin world
and answer everyone's burning question
does
everyone need to be taking a
multivitamin
well let's talk about this according to
the world health organization
more than 2 billion people in the world
have a
micronutrient deficiency so usually iron
calcium
vitamin a b and c research suggests that
consuming adequate nutrients
through food is associated with a
reduced risk of death but consuming
those same
nutrients from supplements doesn't seem
to
have the same effect one analysis of the
research
involving 450 000 people
actually found that multivitamins did
not reduce the risk of heart disease or
cancer in the general population now of
course it is hard to know if the type of
people who are taking multivitamins
regularly
generally have poor quality diets and
therefore
it all evens out but i digress another
concern that also complicates this
research
is that supplements like multivitamins
are notorious for significant variations
between
claimed content and actual content
besides the obvious problem of
not getting what you think you're
getting which we will speak to
in more detail very soon it also makes
it difficult
to evaluate whether any supplement is
improving
health if it's unknown how much of a
vitamin the consumer is actually taking
the other general drawback with
multivitamins
is that you're getting a generalized
bundle of nutrients that may be more
or less than what you uniquely need
so if you were to be working with a
dietitian or a naturopath or your doctor
on this
we would probably want to carefully
analyze your diet
and or blood work to determine your
precise
individual nutrient needs in other words
there is no
one size fits all prescription for
supplements because
it's going to be highly dependent on
your diet
life stage metabolism and health status
and finally also worth noting that some
nutrients are better consumed with food
and others
without and you really don't have an
option to
optimize absorption when everything is
taken at once in one pill so if you were
to go
to a dietitian or at least if you were
to come see me
i wouldn't be giving out blanket
prescriptions for multivitamins
for everyone i would want to look at the
individual needs
of the client to determine what is best
for them
having said that i fully appreciate that
not everyone has the budget or time
to see a nutrition professional about
their unique needs
and i also get that even if you do see a
dietician
you might not have the bandwidth or
budget to fuss over taking
like a bunch of individual vitamins and
pills
a truly effective supplement routine
often takes
commitment so monetary and time
and a lot of folks are just not at that
stage of readiness to commit to
like a handful of pills multiple times a
day
there are also people who are more
likely to benefit from taking a
multivitamin
so folks who are pregnant or nursing
people with severely limited diets
or elderly populations for whom getting
variety and quantity in the diet
can be a challenge so i believe there is
definitely a place
for a multivitamin but it's not
necessary for
everyone but first a quick rundown on
what to look for when choosing a
multivitamin so
first of all let's talk about
bioavailability and absorption
bioavailability is the amount of a
nutrient that is absorbed in the
intestines to be available
for biological activity in your body for
supplements
this isn't just the amount that's
absorbed into the bloodstream
but also how much of the nutrient is
used
by the body or stored for future use
the absorption of some nutrients can be
enhanced by other nutrients or food
so for example the fat soluble nutrients
can be absorbed better with foods that
contain
fat and iron becomes more bioavailable
with the addition of vitamin c there are
also certain forms of vitamins that are
more bioavailable absorbable or just
generally
higher quality because they're a more
active
format so for example i like to choose
methylated folate and b12 because
they're the
active form and a large percentage of
the population
cannot efficiently convert folic acid
now i'm not going to get into detail on
all of these but some of my
preferential forms of various vitamins
can be found on screen
right here next let's discuss quantity
underages
and overages now a lot of multivitamins
go way overboard on quantities because
they're based on outdated daily value
standards from
1968 which was since updated in 2016.
and generally speaking most consumers
think higher amounts of everything is
just better value
but for the general population i try to
avoid vitamins that contain
excessive amounts that are beyond the ul
aka the tolerable upper intake level for
nutrients
particularly the fat soluble ones like
vitamin a e and k
where there is an increased risk for
toxicity and adverse effects
there's generally a bit more flexibility
for water-soluble vitamins because
we do have regulatory mechanisms for
them but
that also means that in most cases
megadoses
aren't beneficial either so if you see a
multivitamin advertised as being
high potency with excessive nutrient
quantities
you might want to take a much closer
look because
more is not necessarily better and more
is not necessarily better when it comes
to the
number and volume of vitamins in a
supplement either
some manufacturers pad their formulas
with massive
laundry lists of vitamins most of which
are in
such small quantities they're more there
for
show than actual function we call this
window dressing personally i would
rather go for a supplement with
fewer nutrients focusing more on the
ones that i
actually need rather than a smorgasbord
of every vitamin and nutrient under the
sun especially because
the more vitamins in a supplement the
more room for
something to go wrong or to interact
with something else you're taking
next let's discuss quality so there's a
few things to think about here
and a lot of this is really more
preference than
anything as i already briefly mentioned
that
some forms of certain vitamins may be
better quality
by nature of being better absorbed
bioavailable
or more active but other considerations
are whether or not the vitamins contain
added sugars artificial sweeteners and
food dyes
for folks who are sensitive to things
like food coloring or certain sugar
alcohols
like i am i once took a bunch of
sugar-free gummy vitamins before bed
and i couldn't figure out why i was up
all night in horrible pain
until i read the label and i saw holy sh
yeah i just unknowingly ate a ton
of xylitol and that stuff doesn't sit
well for me but
speaking of gummies i definitely think
they have their place
particularly for folks who really
struggle to take a pill
or for kiddos who just won't but it's
worth
me pointing out that gummies are
notoriously
hard to manufacture well it's often hard
to measure exactly how much of a
nutrient
is in the vitamin as in some cases
the vitamins are simply like sprayed
onto the candy base
not to mention the vitamins are also
more likely to degrade
so often manufacturers will add more
than what's listed knowing some fit
might not be usable
so it's just hard to know what you're
getting and how much
now third let's quickly consider
preferences
and needs so if you're a woman you might
need a supplement with more iron and
calcium
and that might rule out most gummies on
the market since
iron's metallic flavor usually derails a
lot of
kind of great taste claims now if you're
vegan you might want more vitamin b12
omega-3s calcium and vitamin d and also
would one of course make sure that the
vitamin forms
in the supplement are vegan as well and
if you just cannot
stomach taking a big horse pill like we
talked about
you might want some sort of soft
alternative
generally speaking chewables or soft gel
capsules
are better quality than gummies but of
course
this isn't a rule and there are higher
quality
gummies out there too and we'll talk
more about that in a moment
and finally if you're a busy person
whose supplement routine doesn't run
their life
you might want to consider the
recommendations of the manufacturer
so do you need to take two pills three
times a day with food
or is it one and done deal whenever you
remember
these are important considerations
because there is no point in
buying a supplement if you can't
remember to take it finally
and maybe most importantly is to look
for an option that is
third party tested there is always a
risk of contamination or
overages and underages with supplements
like vitamins
as i discussed in my video on
supplements right here
vitamins are not well regulated
and therefore you aren't always getting
what you
think you're getting this is
particularly an issue with multivitamins
because
there isn't just one vitamin that
they're sourcing there are
multiple touch points where things can
potentially
go wrong this is why it's more important
than ever
that when choosing a vitamin you're
looking for one that is third
party tested you can look for the usp
seal which is a federal certification
program
for establishing supplement standards or
check a third-party testing website
like labdoor.com i also subscribed to
consumerlab.com who did a comprehensive
analysis and report
and shockingly of the 27 multivitamins
they tested
44 of them either contained lower
or higher amounts of the nutrients that
they cleaned or took
longer than permitted to disintegrate in
solution which
would denote a poor absorption rate also
almost all the gummy vitamins they
tested were
problematic so yeah all right so now
that you have a good solid basis upon
which to evaluate your supplements
let me give you my brief analysis of the
vitamins that you most
frequently asked me about i'm just gonna
jump into this quick and dirty style so
this video hopefully isn't an
hour long also a heads up that for easy
comparison's sake
the vitamins we analyzed were for the
women's formulations when available
and the prices were listed in the usd
prices that i found
at the time of this recording so first
let's discuss those that fall under the
category of
regular tablets so i couldn't find much
information on kirkland's women's
formula so i'm going to discuss
their general daily multivitamin here
but it's convenient at one tablet a day
with around 100 of your needs for most
of the vitamins
without going over the upper limit they
are however often found in
lower quality or inactive forms but
kirkland
is usp verified lab door tested
and also tested by consumerlab.com and
while they met all lab doors purity
standards
they did find significant variations in
label claims for a
number of the nutrients especially for
folic acid
so that may be a concern particularly
for
women of childbearing age but at two
dollars a month
it is a very affordable option so i give
it a green light
now mega food has a ton of different
formulations for women
which while a bit overwhelming for a
newbie
it could make it easier to find the best
formulation for you
if you have some direction now mega
foods main differential selling point
is that the nutrients are coming from
whole foods
which sounds great but it's important to
note that this is still
not equivalent to actual whole foods
not to mention you can market a
supplement as being natural
or whole food-based as long as it
contains just
10 percent of its nutrients from
plant-based ingredients
and this is true for mega food so the
usp regulated vitamin or mineral is
delivered
in the food but not exclusively from
food anyways
marketing aside they don't always use
the active or best quality form of some
nutrients
and i also find that a lot of their
formulations contain
a lot of random herbs that you probably
don't need
or want but if you have some
professional direction on
what is safe to take for you personally
i do like that it's just one pill a day
there aren't major overages in
quantities
and of course it is third party tested
so ultimately it passes my test
now mediherb does not have a product
that is labeled explicitly as a
multivitamin
but the closest thing i could find was a
product they call herbivityl
which was intended for healthy aging but
you asked me about it so
here we are it's basically a blend of
herbs like japanese knotweed root
extract milk thistle
korean ginseng grapeseed extract etc
with only six percent of your daily
needs of
calcium you're also supposed to take one
tablet
three to four times daily who the hell
has time for
that uh plus it's pretty pricey and it
does not appear to be third party tested
so
this is getting a hard pass from me now
hum products are actually founded and
formulated by
redshirt dietitians and they're tested
for safety by a third party so that's
great
they don't have a women's formula
specifically
but at one capsule per day the dosage
for their multi
is pretty convenient and while many of
the nutrients were
close to 100 of your needs levels for
vitamin d
and calcium are a little bit low and it
also seems strange to me that there's
over 800
of your needs for vitamin b1 random they
also didn't use the best
quality or active forms of a lot of
nutrients which is
often what happens when you pack a ton
of
vitamins into one pill i also don't like
that a lot of their other products have
questionable names and purposes like
flatter me
for a flatter stomach and counter
cravings
to boost metabolism both of which are
not evidence-based of course but i'm not
reviewing the branding and marketing as
a whole
so i guess for 10 a month they get an
approval stamp
now nature's made vitamin levels are
mostly either at or around 100
and the overages for a few of the
vitamins don't appear to be significant
or
beyond the ul a lot of the nutrients
aren't in the best quality active form
but the serving size is also just one
tablet a day so it is
relatively convenient now labdoor did
rate it highly for product purity
but low for label accuracy with vitamin
c
measuring at nearly half of its stated
claim
but this product is usp certified it's
relatively inexpensive and underages
like this
in a multivitamin are unfortunately
pretty common so
these do get a green light from me now
deva or diva i'm not really sure how you
say it is
labeled as a vegan multivitamin and
mineral supplement
now although many of the vitamins are at
or close to 100
almost all the b vitamins have huge
overages
in the case of vitamin b3 or niacin it's
well over the tolerable upper level
those who supplement with too much
niacin
have reported itchy and red skin all
over their body
headaches other rashes and dizziness
this product is also really low in
calcium something that
those who eat a vegan diet should
probably be more mindful of
and i got a d grading on labdor.com
it actually rated fine for purity
standards but it rated poorly for
projected efficacy
and they found significant label claim
variants on
26 key vitamins particularly
vitamin a so i would probably pass
on deva now cvs is another inexpensive
option most of the vitamins in cvs's
women's blend are
very close to 100 of your daily needs
though some
key ones like calcium and potassium are
very low
it is convenient to take at just one
capsule a day
it's third-party tested and it's super
inexpensive at just
two dollars and fifty cents per month
having said that
a lot of the vitamins are in lower
quality less
optimal forms but if you're on a budget
cvs gets a
green light from me now jamison is a
canadian brand that's marketed as
helping you meet 100 of your body's
daily vitamin needs
with only one capsule per day and while
most of the vitamins are listed
at or close to 100 of your needs
some of the minerals like calcium and
iron are completely
absent they also don't use the active
bioavailable forms of
some nutrients but it is third party
tested and just six dollars a month so
it does get my stamp of approval now
nature's bounties
women's multivitamin has no alarming
overages or unbridges
plus a convenient dosage of just one
tablet per day
most of the vitamins are not the best
quality or active forms but it is third
party tested
usp certified inexpensive and compliant
with
gmp supplement quality standards so you
can add them to your list to try
now one a day is another classic
drugstore brand with
most of the major nutrients found at or
close to 100
of your daily needs you also only have
to take
one a day as the name implies but
a lot of the vitamins aren't in the most
absorbable high quality form
it also uses ferrous fumarate iron which
while very well absorbed isn't always as
well tolerated
so something to keep in mind if you have
a sensitive tummy
having said that it is third party
tested inexpensive
and therefore gets our stamp of approval
okay so
moving on from the harder tablets let's
talk about
soft gels or soft capsule options
so ritual is a favorite for me because
it's third party tested
and usp approved it contains the
bioavailable forms of its nutrients like
methylated b12
and folate and you only need two vegan
soft pills a day now it doesn't have
vitamin a c or calcium and only has
seven percent of your magnesium needs
for the day
so it might not be appropriate if those
are important to you
but it's actually their belief that less
is more
and considering that i personally and
professionally agree that
it's better to get what you need rather
than a lot of what you don't
i actually really like this minimalist
approach so
ritual gets my stamp of approval now
another popular
millennial product the care of
multivitamin
is a little bit lower in some of the
major nutrients of concern
like calcium vitamin a and e
but they do use higher quality forms of
nutrients
and chelated iron for sensitive tummies
plus
they are third party tested in nsf and
gmp certified facilities for safety and
purity so
this gets a thumbs up from me now
similar to the
mega food brand weber's multivitamin
contains
a lot of superfood and herb blends like
wheatgrass
juice powder and green tea polyphenols
and turmeric and ginger extract and
alfalfa juice powder etc
most of which i see as window dressing
seeing as
i can't imagine what getting 15
milligrams
of cruciferous vegetables is really
gonna do
also in a lot of cases it seems it's
at the expense of the actual vitamins
since a lot of the key nutrients like
calcium and iron come up short it also
doesn't contain the
methylated active versions of folate and
b12
but it is manufactured in a gmp facility
and it's third party tested so this
still gets a green light from me
now nfh doesn't have a women's formula
just the general multi
so we looked at that not only is nfh
validated by third party labs but they
are also an
eqp gold partner meaning it meets the
emerson quality gold program standards
for quality assessment
however things get a little bit messy
when we look into the actual ingredients
the values for many of the b vitamins
are well over the recommended intake
with b12 coming in at over 40 000
percent of your daily needs and folate
is over
400 which for some folks could actually
be dangerous
there's also significant underages for a
number of important vitamins like
vitamin e and d and you have to take
three capsules every day
so this is a brand that i actually
really love for individual vitamins
but maybe wouldn't be my first choice
for a multivitamin
but it still ultimately gets the green
light now cytomatrix's
dosage is two capsules twice per day
which
for some folks just maybe isn't very
realistic or convenient
i do like to see that most of the
nutrients like b6
and b12 are available in their
bioavailable forms
but some key nutrients like calcium iron
and most notably d are a bit low
this company also appears to be gmp
compliant
and third party tested and there aren't
hugely significant overages or underages
in this one so ultimately it gets a
thumbs up from me
now vivo life doesn't have a women's
formula but
their vegan multi-nutrient and mineral
supplement is recommended to be taken
at one capsule twice daily which again
is not necessarily super convenient most
of the vitamins are provided
close to 100 of your needs but it is
quite low in
key nutrients like vitamin k calcium and
iron
and there's no folate which would
probably be important for a lot of women
but it is third-party tested for heavy
metals
and other contaminants and it is fully
vegan
so ultimately it has my stamp of
approval now canned prev's multi
offers most of its nutrients at or close
to 100 of your needs
and uses the active forms of b12 and
folate which is great
but my biggest criticism with the can
prev is that you're supposed to take it
three times a day i don't know i find
two times a day is already pretty
cumbersome
so to remember a midday pill just might
not happen for most people
but can prep products are manufactured
at
gmp facilities and are third party
tested so
these do get the green light from me
next up
is natural factors women's multivitamin
which is dosed at three capsules per day
now while most of the nutrients are
supplied in appropriate quantities
a lot of the vitamins are not in their
highest quality active forms
now my biggest concern with this one is
that it's padded with a ton of herbs
enzymes and extracts with little to no
evidence to support them
which i think most people would probably
see is like a good thing
but as i already mentioned it just adds
more room for air
and adverse interactions in my books
having said that
it is third party tested so while it
wouldn't be my first choice
it's still likely a credible safe choice
so
it does get the green light from me now
is another popular
three soft gel per day option a lot of
the b
vitamins are in pretty high quantities
and the folate isn't methylated for
those who are looking for that there's
also a bunch of window dressings like
evening primrose oil cranberry
concentrate grape seed extract
etc and in the case of something like
evening primrose oil
you would probably want to make sure
that it was appropriate
for you having said that now is
certified by
a bunch of regulatory bodies and it's
relatively inexpensive
so it does get the green light from me
and finally garden of life
packs a ton of different vitamins most
of which are found in
higher quality active form but the
folate is not methylated which
you know i would like to see the issue
is that you're supposed to take
four capsules total two times a day
which
might be a lot for us to well swallow
that's what she said
don't you dare there's also a lot of
enzymes and probiotics and other
antioxidants
a lot of which are not evidence-based
and you're paying for
all of those bells and whistles at 45
45.99
per month they are however heavily
tested and audited so
despite being one of the most expensive
options
they ultimately get a green light now
lastly we obviously have to talk about
every influencer's favorite way to get
their vitamins
gummies i mean they are pretty delicious
but they are not
to be taken as candy now ollie's women's
multivitamins come in the form of two
gummies per day
which supplies two grams of added sugar
some of their nutrients
are pretty low most notably calcium at
eight percent of your needs
and a lot of the vitamins are presented
in lower quality forms
most problematically while the ali
website says that all products are
produced in
gmp facilities and are audited by the
fda and third party certifiers
ollie has failed testing by consumer lab
in the past
for having huge overages that were not
listed on the label
this is pretty common with gummy
vitamins which i already mentioned are
difficult to control
and manufacture but i do have greater
concerns with
overages than underages in these cases
they're also not vegetarian as the
gummies contain gelatin
so just a heads up for all my
plant-based friends
but there are no artificial flavors or
colors which
i personally like finally the brand
offers a wide range of blends that
aren't necessarily
well supported by the literature like a
blend for
better sex drive and sensation called
lovin libido and a happy hoo-ha blend
for
vaginal ph balance so
yeah they technically get a green light
for safety
but they wouldn't be my first choice now
the serving size for
smartypants multivitamin gummy is six
gummies daily which admittedly feels
like a lot
it also provides six grams of added
sugar now the b
vitamins a k and calcium are pretty low
or non-existent which again
is not uncommon in a gummy vitamin
and they're not vegetarian as they
contain gelatin
but they are third party tested and they
use higher quality active forms of
vitamins in there so
well gummies are typically not my first
pick
they definitely get the green light from
me now with two gummies per day
vita fusion supplies three grams of
added sugar
and while most of the nutrients clock in
at 100 of your needs
it is low in calcium and lacks vitamin k
and iron a lot of the vitamins are also
lower in quality
or not in active forms but this brand is
certified by
third parties and gmps so ultimately
they get the green light now herbalance
unisex gummy multivitamin
is recommended to take two capsules two
times per day which
again not the most convenient now while
most of the vitamins are close to 100 of
your needs
it is a little low in vitamin d with no
iron or
calcium and they also don't use
methylated folate
now unlike most gummy vitamins these
ones are sugar-free
but they contain a variety of artificial
sweeteners and sugar alcohols
that maybe are not digested so well for
people
who are sensitive to fodmaps that being
said they are third party tested
and i've tried them and they do taste
pretty good
so for gummies i would give this a green
light
there was a lot of information there
for you to swallow that's what she said
or he said or chew i guess your choice
but to recap most multivitamins are
produced by
reputable companies and are third party
tested but as reports from
places like consumerlab and labdor.com
suggest
it doesn't mean they're always perfect
ultimately
which multivitamin you choose is going
to come down to
your unique needs your budget and
accessibility
so if you think you need a multivitamin
i hope this gives you some information
for choosing the right option for you
if you're wondering how your vitamins
stack up you can check out labdoor.com
and read the manufacturer's website very
carefully
for information on their testing
procedures and on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today
thanks again to omnia for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
about what you'd like to see here for
you next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye